after if you left the wine what word
best describes you over there and go
around I'm silly boy oh very happy dizzy
I'm selfish lazy and we are here with
Little Big Town doing an interview under
the influence
I'm so excited ever since I heard that
you guys were launching this wine I have
been dying to try it I don't me about
the process of doing this because I
named a cousin super involved in it yeah
we know we made a great relationship
with Andrew Brown and the Brown family
bring music in a long process because we
didn't want to just throw our name
bottle of wine we drink a lot of wine
you know good line I'm going to
confidently say that we write a lot of
songs when we're drinking wine it's good
pass right off baby okay so I can play a
little game with you guys I love playing
never ever ever when we were first a van
when we had to drive ourselves just the
four of us all over the country and we
would play never have ever gave us away
I kept waiting yeah so that's kind of
how we started finding out of anything
boys so I'm so excited to get to a
little bit more about you guys there's a
fun question here
never have I ever put ice cubes in my
wine never
I am wondering whatever garbage yeah so
if you have we're going to take a bowl
and keep drinking
okay never have I ever drank straight
from the model
[Music]
really I've done time for you
elegant idiot revenue just get right to
the point never have I ever performed
after a few too many drinks okay so now
you have to tell me a little bit of a
story like like what well that we were
playing a label function I remember this
one specifically and Kenny Rogers was
there and you're gonna blame it on her
no he brought up a shot of tequila's
akimbo remember and you did a sad one I
never had a chance to take in the two
shots of tequila in her life probably
and guessing a beer with Matthew
McConaughey and Kenny rug pretty good
company all right I'll never have I ever
written a ridiculous song while drunk a
nice thick and profession can use these
songs for the light of day do we know
any songs that you wrote all the round
red rooms yeah yes they're kind of away
on their silly pop certain company we
keep together a little raunchy
what about never have I ever written a
great song Walter oh you know we're out
greater they were pretty
we were pretty tipsy okay so we have an
icon from the last record and then
lovers ones I was referencing yes yeah
the rock oh yeah yes that was a late
night sometimes and if it don't down
your
[Music]
awesome yeah she will yes it's rude but
I think we work in their genes
she was important oh there oh she was
very she wasn't really yeah make you
more creative I feel like I'm a little
bit more free with my words after I've
had yeah I learned the voices up in your
head you know sometimes you can get all
in your head and you start you know
thinking too much every hour relaxes you
never have I ever have an awkward run-in
with another celebrity Oh every
interaction I had with Blake is yeah
started thinking about you usually we're
drinking around Blake okay he's just
offered in general in this while
drinking or just a drop in general yeah
I felt I felt onto Dolly Parton once and
that was you trying to meet her up on a
cell onto her lap that was awkward if
you're going to fall into somebody's lap
though like I didn't make it to the lab
never member ever build red wine on
something expensive
oh did you can you still read one on
somebody's like really specific you
still read one in it
oh my own this and an airplane yeah yeah
that's it takes to drink
are you okay never have I ever been
kicked out of a bar and I expect stories
of you have have you been keeping it
that way I but it wasn't totally my
fault
no I was with her group and one of the
girls it was kind of like dancing
J&B shakes us all out fathers okay
guilty by Sophia okay I'm out of the
casino once remember all of them oh my
casino show on a commune reservation so
I had land and like like was their place
opened Zack and we did respect the rules
for the showers
except to our dressing room and then
there everybody was there and we decided
that we were welcome pastoring did we
got my trouble can a single we were loud
the party moved elsewhere
yeah right does it for can move in the
parking lot
okay last one you guys never have I ever
lied during this game good oh my god
thank you guys so much mister spell
delicious I need to try the red and
after his telephone at home where they
can get the line how they can be a part
of the family you can go to for sellers
calm and it's going on longer
yep ll ers yeah Little Big Town calm yes
okay every week cheer cheer diet yay
thank you so much bro hey we're Little
Big Town and remember when you're having
a glass of wine to drink responsibly and
don't drive nope call your friends they
come get me and subscribe to ETS YouTube
channel